you know I think about your life and you
were married at an early age to a guy
Jill's Ben Simone he's a famous fashion
photographer and The Story Goes that uh
you didn't speak a word of French but in
six months you learned French fluently
yeah that's very much in love yeah are
you a genius you tested in the top
percentile of essay whatever the
equivalent in the top three percent of
the country in my final studies and I
went to you know I
applied to University to study law
that's what I wanted to do like my
stepfather was a lawyer why didn't you
go into law because you were so
beautiful no not at all I took a gap
year because I was young you know I
finished school I was 16 and nine months
and I was going to go and study law at
17. how do you finish school at 16. how
does that happen in nine months that was
just that's the way the system is in
Australia I see so you took the SAT I
took my final exams I did quite well
because I studied hard not because I'm
particularly bright right
um and I you know I got into University
and then I took a gap year and and then
during that Gap year I started of
modeling how old were you then 16 17.
did your mother did she become a model
then I mean most people I went somehow
no it wasn't discovered a friend of mine
A girlfriend of mine said to me I've
started this modeling thing you can earn
quite a lot of money I thought I like
the idea of that she said I bet you 20
bucks if you go to my modeling agency
they'll take you on I thought even if I
lose I win 20 bucks 20 bucks was a lot
of time and that a lot of money at that
age for me and it was at least three
hours work at the pharmacy I was working
at right and so I went along to this
modeling agency and uh and they took me
on and then I started working you were
always known as the body right that was
your thing the body no actually and tell
you the truth with that was that when
time coined the body I thought to myself
hey very smart how can I capitalize on
this right and that's when I started to
build a brand around body products the
body Consciousness body Wellness
and so it's not a really a an ego place
like oh wow look at me don't I have a
great body it was more a business
decision that I made in 1986.